hey 42 here every year millions of
people visit the seaside
to enjoy the sun and the waves it's a
charming sight to see happy
holidaymakers playing with their balls
and splashing about in the ocean then
again it's obvious these nutters haven't
paid even a moment's thought
to what they're sharing the water with
and i don't just mean gallons upon
gallons of their fellow sun seekers
urine
the ocean is full of all sorts of weird
and scary creatures
only a maniac would knowingly and
willingly spend time around
the obvious place to start is with
sharks of course sharks in general
have a bad but largely unfair reputation
as being the killers of the sea your
chances of being attacked by a shark are
only about 1 in 3.75 million
less than the chance of dying from a
lightning strike
or meeting beyonce now i'll admit those
odds will shorten considerably if you're
the kind of
weird person who'd like swimming around
in open water whilst wearing the still
bleeding carcasses of recently deceased
fish
but hey if that's your thing i'd argue
you're asking for it
most sharks are scary in a fairly
run-of-the-mill
it's going to eat me kind of way i'm
looking at you great white
but other less well-known varieties
bring their own brand of weird to add to
the deadly mix
take the thrilled shark for example with
a snake-like body that grows to be over
2 metres long
and 300 razor-edged teeth spread across
25 rows it basically looks like the
world's most dangerous eel
i wonder if it has balls but there
are far weirder creatures waiting out
there in the sea
than sharks take the sarcastic
fringe fringehead for example so named
for its tendency to make snarky comments
about its mates
apart from having the best name of any
creature in the sea
or anywhere else for that matter the
sarcastic fringehead is able to expand
its entire face into one massive mouth
when it feels threatened so basically
like a more sarcastic version
of predator except it lives in a shell
and probably can't turn invisible
also hanging out on the ocean floor and
eating
dead stuff is the giant isopod it's
totally harmless but looks like a two
and a foot half long version
of your worst cockroach nightmare then
there's the northern stargazer he sounds
friendly enough
but this bug-eyed creep of a face that
looks like it's been crapped out by a
sea cucumber
burrows itself into the ocean floor
before electrocuting passing victims
with extreme prejudice and
whilst i'm talking about sea cucumbers
have you ever seen anything so
unfortunate
they look like the love child of a slug
and the large ball of snot
and i can tell you from experience
they're absolutely useless if you want
to make tzatziki
far more disgusting than this though is
the pearl fish
which hides from predators by burrowing
into the sea cucumber's anus
talk about living in the arse end of
town
i could go on forever with the list of
the freakiest freaks of the seven seas
naming cannibalistic lobsters sea lice
sea fleas and even a delightful
flesh-eating bacteria
but let me save us some time by zooming
in on nature's
most finely tuned blend of scary
and gross it's a worm that grows up to
three meters long
and digs itself into the sea floor
leaving
only the tip of its body exposed that
body has a hard outer shell coloured
like a rainbow
but not exactly in a care bears kind of
way
the worm's head if you can call it a
head
is decorated with five antennae it uses
to sense its prey
and a pharynx a set of vicious jaws that
can snap tight on a fish so quickly and
with so much force
the unlucky critter is sometimes split
clean
in two frankly that's probably the best
way to go
because the rest of this worms victims
often way bigger than the worm itself
are dragged back to its underground
house before they
even know what's happening scientists
don't yet
know what goes on in the worms lair but
it's definitely not pretty
take a moment to look at this
nightmarish creature
and tell me what you see if you're
jumping up and down on your couch
shouting
dismembered penis well done
because this animal brought to you
straight out of satan's own nightmares
is the bobbit worm apparently named
after a rather unfortunate incident in
the early 90s
when lorena bobbitt sliced off her
husband
john's penis in case you don't remember
the details of the story
lorena whose maiden name was kuciakov
it wasn't i made that up claimed in
court
her husband was abusive and had
one night finally gone too far
whilst john claimed he was the innocent
victim
of a woman with a bad case of cray-cray
both went on trial for different crimes
causing a worldwide
media sensation though both were
ultimately acquitted
lorena went on to lead a fairly normal
life as a beauty technician
and as an advocate for survivors of
domestic violence
john followed a more eclectic career arc
dabbling in construction work truck
driving
circus performance wwe wrestling
appearances
and even starring in two adult films
which were dubious by even porn
standards
john wayne bobbitt uncut and
john wayne bobbitt's franken penis in
case you're wondering how john was able
to
uh perform in these classics of the
silver screen
his manhood was actually in full working
order
thanks to an amazing doctor who managed
to sew everything back together
after police found john's penis
abandoned in a field lorena
had thrown it out of the window of her
car whilst taking a drive to cool off
in the aftermath of the whole
penis-severing thing
the plastic surgeon in question was
experienced in microsurgery
and had previously put together fingers
and the likes
but he'd never done the same job with a
penis
astonishingly despite having no memory
of performing this operation before
he somehow managed to successfully
remember just in time
so how did this mess of a story lend
itself to the naming of a worm at the
bottom of the sea
is it because the worm looks like it's
being cut in half
or is it perhaps because it sticks out
further and further the more excited it
gets
the answer to that lies with dr terry
goslinger
a senior curator at the california
academy of sciences
who gave the bobbitt worm its common
name according to gosliner he first saw
the worm in the wild
in 1992 and included it in his reference
book
coral reef animals of the indo-pacific
this was around the time of the bobbitt
trial and the marine researcher
apparently felt inspired by the
similarity between
what lorena bobbitt had done to her
husband
and the bobert worm's ability to cut
through a fish's spinal column
with its scissor-like jaws obvious right
if you're freud of course the bobbitt
worm has a real name
eunice aphrodite but most people seem to
prefer the one inspired by the severed
penis
so we'll go with that it forms part of a
class of segmented worms called polyketa
named after the ketus or brittles
typically found running along their
bodies
some polyketers use their bristles for
self-defense
like the firework that can cause
terrible skin reactions if touched
the bobbit worm doesn't seem to use its
bristles in this way though
instead they're probably useful for
locomotion helping the worm to move up
and down its borrow
as quickly as it does as for that burrow
i don't really want to imagine what goes
on down there
especially not if you're a fish
unfortunate enough to have been captured
ecologists specializing in polyketas
suspects the worm first injects its prey
with a toxin
that allows it to then ingest and digest
its food but all of this is speculation
because the bobbit worm
has so rarely been studied in its
natural environment
in fact as a testament to its special
level of weird
we aren't even sure if we know how to
classify this thing properly in the
first place
when classifying biological organisms
scientists follow
a naming hierarchy which is basically
like a family tree
at the top is the domain of which there
are three
bacteria archaea which are single-celled
organisms without a cell nucleus
and eukarya which are organisms made up
of cells
with a nucleus pretty much anything you
might think of as a visible living thing
including yourself your dog that
mold growing on your bread or your
neighbor daryl
is part of that domain within each
domain there are three different
kingdoms such as
animals plants and fungus again
you and your dog are part of the kingdom
of animals whilst a mold
and daryl are part of the kingdom called
fungus
within each kingdom there are multiple
filler in the animal kingdom there are
and you and your dog fall within the
film cordata
because you have a backbone at least
most of the time
within filler there are classes you and
your dog form part of the class mammalia
whilst as you'll recall our friend
eunice aphrodite
the bobbit's worm is part of the
polyketa class
classes are broken into different orders
and this is where you and your dog part
weighs
because you form part of the primates
and she belongs to the carnivorous
orders break down into different
families such as the hominids which is
where humans fit in
along with other great apes and then
families are divided into genera
which are further divided into species
our species is homo sapiens your dogs is
canis lupus
or canis familiaris depending on which
biologist you're drinking with
and daryl's well we're not sure about
daryl
and it turns out people aren't sure
about the bobbit worm either
initially it was thought to be its own
species but it could be a whole new
genus altogether
i want to say we should call it daryl
but maybe a more appropriate name
would be barry in 2008 a nukey blue reef
aquarium in england
started noticing problems in one of
their tanks
coral was being moved around and broken
and
prized fish were being attacked but
there is no evidence of a culprit
the curator and his team laid traps at
night
but those were destroyed too even the
hooks disappeared
the only thing left to do was to drain
the tank
and dismantle it one rock at a time and
that's when
barry showed up a 1.2 meter long
bobbit worm who'd been camping out
undetected
in the sand of the tank floor it's
thought barry probably arrived in his
larval state
hidden in a piece of coral that was
added to the tank
and then grew fat on the easy pickings
in the wild the bobbitt worm sticks to
warmer waters in the atlantic
and indo-pacific and is believed to live
three to five years which is
unnecessarily long in my opinion
it also seems to have been around for
ages hundreds of fossilized worm boros
dating back
20 million years were recently found in
taiwan
and scientists believe they were either
made by bobbitt worms
or something very similar because
invertebrates like worms hardly ever
fossilize
they're much too squishy it's impossible
to say with certainty
but by the shapes of the creatures
burrows it seems like this two meter
long
thin cylindrical animal was lurking in
the sea floor
jumping out to catch prey and then
dragging it back underground
sound familiar but there is some debate
about whether these ancient fossils
really do belong to ancient bobbitt
worms
dr terry gosliner the phallus-minded
marine researcher we met
earlier says the same fossil markings
could have been made by something far
more docile than the bobbitt worm
he's so lovingly named but it's hard to
say because no one has really studied
the burrows of living specimens yet
so we have nothing to compare the
fossils to
on the topic of dark romantic hideaways
you're probably not wondering what the
bobbitt worm gets up to when it's
feeling randy
but i'm going to tell you anyway the
truth is
we don't really know we can only guess
based on the behavior of other
polychettas
for them spawning usually happens during
a very small window of time brought
about by the seasons
the faces of the moon and possibly
candlelight
and the bottle of merlot females attract
males by releasing pheromones into the
water
which drives the males nuts and
encourages them to release plumes of
sperm
in response the females release clouds
of eggs and fertilization happens
somewhere in the floating
currents overhead i can definitely think
of more enjoyable ways to achieve a
similar result
but this is the way most polycheaters do
things or
don't do things depending on how you
look at it
in some versions of this process males
and females
have specially adapted back ends filled
with sperm and eggs
then when spawning starts the worms swim
towards the surface
before releasing their loads like i said
earlier
i can think of a hundred good reasons
not to go paddling about in the sea
but the idea of duck diving for a cloud
are three meter long monster worms and
their sperm
is right near the top of that list
thanks for watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you